mon pair de cellule je pense que tu m'as sauvé la vie de la
neige maintenant je te dois une grande faveur je vais
te dire quelque chose ça va le
même étrange d'accord je suis mort dans un incendie
nous avons besoin de quelqu'un pour trouver l'incendiaire tu as
jamais eu quelqu'un après toi je voulais  pour
te blesser la
dernière fois Java a brûlé une maison
censée être vide alors que s'est-il passé la personne
dans la maison tu as brûlé des maisons ces derniers temps
tout ce qui me concerne ça va
bien défendez-vous probablement
je suis debout monsieur hé hé doucement sur la voiture je
mets  je ne veux pas qu'il t'arrive quelque chose des
billets arrivent déjà
celui qui t'a fait ça il doit
être obligé de payer comme si c'était si dur de maintenant
il y a des choses dans ce monde je ne sais pas
une fois que David je serai
Est-ce que les choses se sont passées comme vous l'aviez prévu Tout ce qui doit arriver
va arriver
- Morty
à
J'espère que tu
oh elle sera toujours là